it's Hamburg Germany the year is 1669
inside of a basement laboratory
Alchemist Henning brand is boiling
gallons of urine to create the fabled
Philosopher's Stone unbeknownst to him
the urine is about to lead to a truly
world altering discovery during the
Middle Ages the Philosopher's Stone was
the coveted discovery because it was
believed it could turn ordinary metal to
gold in his quest to find it brand
accumulated over 1,500 gallons of urine
he thought that by purifying the waste
the Philosopher's Stone would
materialize in what was left the process
went like this one age the urine until
an intense odour billows out of the
samples to boil the urine until a white
paste materializes three place the
heated paste in a retort for gold will
then drip out of the wait what okay so
it wasn't gold that emerged but a solid
white substance that glowed in the dark
this was big this was bigger than big
his discovery was gonna change the world
brand had discovered phosphorus one of
the building blocks of life making him
the first person to ever discover a
chemical element but the thing was he
had no idea he believed he had found a
glowing Philosopher's Stone and named
the substance phosphorus meaning bringer
of light brand kept his discovery a
secret until he eventually sold his
process to other scientists it wasn't
until after his death that he was given
credit for discovering phosphorus all by
boiling urine in his basement laboratory
[Music]